hello everyone and welcome to the
assassin's creed mirage trailer
breakdown i'm yusuf mageed and i'm
joined by creative director stefan
boudon narrative director sarah bullio
and art director jean-luc sala who are
going to explain some of the details we
saw in this brand new trailer i am
now
sarah i want to pause right here because
we get our first look at bassin we gotta
first look at young bassom why did you
want to go back and tell this origin
story how how old is he here how many
years before the bastion we know in
valhalla is this so we are 20 years
before valhalla
around 20 years bassim is around 70
years old on the trailer here it's
actually the beginning of the game he's
going to be around 17. we chose actually
bassem and we wanted to tell his origin
story because as you know maybe from
valhalla
he's a very charismatic character
already
and there was
basically a blank page between the
moment when actually basim was raised in
samara by his father and the moment when
we meet him in valhalla he is also
someone that is going to become an
assassin and it was logical for us as we
wanted to go back to the roots to
actually showcase and and let the player
experience this coming of age and this
whole becoming a nasa same topic we are
working with an actor called limash duke
who is voicing bassem and
just actually we're very happy to have
him on board he's a great great actor
ready to sacrifice everything your
health clothes
i am
so we are very lucky to have a composer
so brendan angelidis who is working on
the soundtrack of the game who also
actually did the soundtrack for the
trader the music that you hear in the
trailer is actually in line with the
guidelines and the music from the game
itself the composer brendan actually
used some um some instruments that are
very authentic that are really conveying
this arabic atmosphere and vibe that we
wanted and that we
were very
eager to to respect as much as possible
[Music]
are you ready to leave your life behind
so this is russian
russian is one of our key characters
she's bassim's mentor she's gonna be
here right from the beginning of the
game until the end and we have the great
pleasure to be working with a great
actress russian is going to be voiced by
shuri agudashlu who is a navy
award-winning actress and we are very
happy to have her on board so russian is
a woman of 50 a really skilled hidden
one she's gonna be keep to bastan's
evolution as a character also a lot of
characters
and walk the path of shadows
i am
placim has a lot of potential for
becoming
ident one is a gifted young thief first
and also he shares with them the same
ideology of freedom and free will the
symbol also unique legacy
as well and russian will notice it
obviously so that's why for all those
elements it will be a very key asset for
the ident ones then out of the dark you
will come into the light
[Music]
this is not massive but uh it's a
tribute to uh ac one and also to the
lore of assassins because in the lore
the birthplace is an amut a fortress in
the northern mountains of iron and this
is it this is the first time we are
going to show in an ac game the citadel
of alamut
we are at this moment at the tipping
point of
hidden ones and the assassins
brotherhood which is going to be
there in alamuts in 100 use it's going
to take a long time to finish this
fortress but this is the very beginning
of the end of the even once
[Music]
this is a love letter to ac one i think
everybody got it seen this trailer we
saw
russian we see basim they were the
levantine white outfit with a little
touch of you know arabic
style just like the shemag and the
pompom this is definitely going to be
his role here is a coming of age of an
assassin so yeah it is really looking
like one
and i just want to i just want to make a
note right now to all the viewers
watching make note of this pose right
here that roshan oh yes and then
uh we just see it again
yeah during his training blessing can be
impetus but which can lead him to learn
the lessons the hard way you know
and from the light
you will return to the dark
[Music]
the ceremony moment was discussed pretty
early also alamut was discussed pretty
early in the conception phase it was
something that we wanted to showcase
because it's so
so important in the in the assassin's
creed lore it's a whole ceremony that
you have to think about how it's going
to happen what people are going to say
and it's uh it's actually a pretty
powerful
thing to work on honestly and it was
also great to deep dive inside all the
material the paced ac games brings us
so i'm not gonna lie it was a challenge
for us of course because we have a ton
of material and at the end it was very
satisfying working with sarah jean-luc
to see all the connections we succeeded
to make inside assassin's creed mirage
yeah and if i may had we
we reversed engineered passing because
basement valley has a cut finger so we
needed to explain why his figure was cut
so we know it's a typical feature
of the
early assassins yeah i think it's part
of the process we we break down the
basim of allah the look of him and try
to see what is the kind of
visual tags costume parts he can have
early on and try to explain
why he saw that is still there
but also
our story is uh
has a beginning and an end and and it's
key to us to to make it accessible to to
every player not only the players that
actually know the franchise very well
but also the newcomers for example it's
both a love letter but also a nature
driven game that is really focused on on
a character and how he evolves
this is back that you know the usual
question is when the next assad scenes
or where the next assassins pre game is
going to happen and uh now you know so
this is going to be back that you can
only see one district here which is a
[ __ ] district uh the district of the
bazaar but you can have also a view
on the background of the
californ palace which is a very center
the earth of the empire and also the out
of the city it's called around city
because there is a round fortification
all around and uh inside that
fortification you do have the highest
peak of civilization outside it's more
the regular city with different
districts one dedicated to science one
dedicated to trading one dedicated to
industry one dedicated to uh almost
military defense which is sharky it's a
sub district this is uh yeah you know
perfect playground bringing good old
vibes from previous ac games we are back
in middle east we are back in this kind
of you know light density the vivid
colors i think this is also something we
love we know ac one and we are happy to
come back to places in middle east but
also this is going to be a complete
surprise to see how much uh that city
was big as you can see a lot of
opportunities for parkour and a lot of
promises of adventure
you cannot have the peak of civilization
without having you know war injustice
and such yeah for me this is a perfect
playground for you know doing assessing
stuff
yeah we spend a lot of energy to bring
back crowds this is a really really
breathing living city a city that never
sleeps also so you will see that and we
also try to bring as many people as we
can on the streets
stay your blade from the flesh of the
innocent
hide in plain sight
never compromise the brotherhood
the smoke bomb are bags and a lot of
assassins tool you will be able to use
at your advantage on a very specific
situation so we have a three knife blow
dart
mine also noise maker and all those
tools will be fully upgradable and you
will be able to change their effect or
their behaviors during your pressure
[Applause]
you will be able to control your eagle
his name
is
enkidu we will bring back also and i'm
very pleased to announce that the
possibility of marking the enemies with
your eagle as it is very important for
us to give strong record tools to the
player to perform the best death
approach
[Music]
from this day forward
you are
a hidden one so the creation of the
assassin uh brotherhood will happen a
bit later during the 10th century
with the reformation of the ident one by
asan isaba
but we are very very close of this
transformation
in assassin's creed mirad and you can
already see it feel it in the game and i
love the the shot of bassam on the perch
dropping down it's very reminiscent of
the ac2 trailer there's a ton of
callbacks and throwbacks in this and i i
love it
[Music]
oh first this is a mass of the uh order
of the ancient so a kind of you know
artifact we are used to now since ac
origin and odyssey we do have it in
mirage too this mask is connected to the
past of this land we are in baghdad and
the civilization just before is the
babylonian one so that's why he has this
kind of babylonian face and
honestly this is not the only mask you
are going to see all the masks created
for the game are just gorgeous this
specific cell of the order of the
ancients is is one of the last remaining
cells as it will soon start its
transformation also to a new
organization exactly
like the ident ones
[Music]
so sarah here we see bassim perform the
same move that roshan performed on him
and this is something we've seen
throughout the trailer he fails at one
point and then he learns and he grows um
are we going to get to see bassem evolve
throughout the game
yes sure as you saw at the beginning of
the trailer bassim starts from being a
street c to a master assassin he's going
to be able to perform
moves that he was not able to perform at
the beginning of the game we're going to
really see this evolution and and the
player is actually going to be able to
experience this very deeply through all
the games
[Music]
we are
homage tribute to a first assassin's
game and we wanted to to be really
really close to the original levantine
assassins crest actually there is
something written on it it's the arabic
phrase for hidden one
so it has a lot of sense in the game to
have this kind of hidden message in a
game about the hidden ones it has been
made by a very wonderful artist atama
rafa is a very very well-known and
skilled calligraphic artist he also
worked on something you will discover
while playing the game which is our
skill tree and it will feature some
wonderful piece of arabic calligraphy on
the on the ui you know every assassin's
creed game is trying to make a kind of
you know
magic trick with uh with the crest uh
i'm really happy about what we've done
with ours
this creature that you see here which is
a gene this creature is going to be an
important part of bastion's evolution
and it's going to be present in in every
memory colloidals as we call them so
that moment when basin kills a target it
has its secret it has its meaning
and yes i'm not gonna say much more but
you're gonna discover that in the
storyline oh well that's the perfect
tease sir thank you so much i can't wait
to find out more and for everyone
watching you'll be able to find out more
when assassin's creed mirage launches
later in 2023
[Music]
you